[Music]
all right
this article here is pretty funny
it has a video and i'm wondering if you
guys have seen it have you seen a video
of a sign language interpreter recently
go viral recently
not recently but i've seen that sign
interpreter for obama
that one time i think was it for obama
or snoop dogg at the
concert no not at the concert it was a
speech
it was out of speech like a political
speech i forgot
a lot of enthusiasm with the scientist
no it was just enthusiastic yeah like it
was signing but then like he
didn't know what he was doing no that
was that obama yeah that's what i'm
saying like i don't know if it was obama
somewhere in africa left shark didn't
know he was yeah
it was fun she's confusing black people
i'm sorry what
um but it was in africa they what was it
was it south africa
i don't know but it was like some sort
of political thing yeah yeah yeah
that's why i thought obama because i was
like check let's see if the sign
language all right just
this lady like picked her away so she
just kind of faked signings no that was
a dude
or somebody thinks science was a fake
scientist a different situation
he was fake in one she's probably
thinking a different one i don't know he
was like fake signing and he was like
all [ __ ] into it and [ __ ]
yeah and then like they realized that he
wasn't actual like
he wasn't a real translator yeah we did
on jake and news like long ago
but this one though this one's recent
and it was
a sign language interpreter uh
interpreting
for a honolulu may or for the honolulu
mayor
named kirk caldwell and he was doing a
press conference
and you will see what happened
oh i can't wait okay
ready make sure to boost the volume in
this one oh
it's boosted they can almost be together
but you can't invite
your auntie and cuz from another
household over to your house
to have dinner um that is that is a
gathering
that is prohibited
you know the guys that come by our house
and protest it you know we
we allow that in our country
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
for those of you guys watching that
didn't catch what happened this uh there
was a man
out in the crowd that ended up yelling
to the mayor
[ __ ] you and the language interpreter
ended up flipping off
as a sign for [ __ ] you and she just kept
going very professional
and then also very professional of the
mayor did you guys hear his response
yeah you responded to it
he was like yeah that's you can protest
if you want that's what you're doing
yeah so initially what the mayor was
saying
is he was talking about like the current
restrictions right now the stay at home
order and work from home order and
uh he was saying that would continue for
the next two weeks in order to
lessen the coronavirus cases in that
region and so he was saying that parks
beaches and trails would reopen for
and would reopen to allow for solo
activities including reading meditating
eating lunch jogging and sitting on the
beach and all that stuff
where is he hawaii yeah and then
he ends up saying like you know this is
exact quote you can only
you can only get one household in one
household
your friends from another household are
prohibited or should not be coming to
your house to gather we're trying to
really bring down the spread of the
virus
you can't invite your auntie and cuz
from another household over to your
house to have dinner that is a gathering
that is prohibited
that's when the guy was like [ __ ] you i
just think it's so cool that the
the the governor or the mayor of
honolulu uses the words cuz
as i don't you don't hear politicians
like you slang
auntie and queen what else is i think
that the [ __ ] you guy
if you listen to the vector of the [ __ ]
you and the lack of muffling he wasn't
wearing a mouse oh
or maybe he he lowered it you think the
guy was yelling [ __ ] you
to the mayor's wearing them i sure hoped
so
he was just like but i'm being
responsible actually
because now i'm nasty right like it's
like it doesn't work
or you can't project as well you can't
really wonder how you would muffle like
interpret like a muscle yeah you can't
enunciate like
yeah like this behind your hand
thinly veiled
but yeah after the [ __ ] you did you
notice how she kind of hesitated yeah
but it's she was i mean she's on it
she's like definitely picking up she's
like well
i mean the people are gonna definitely
had a debate in her head where she was
like is this something i should sign
yeah yeah they need context yeah and her
body was just like yeah okay i guess
we're doing this
[Laughter]
pretty much did she get uh in trouble
for doing it because
on a professional level i wonder if it
was cool with them to just flip off i'm
sure
it's true like television tv i don't
know well there's kids watching yeah i
mean with their parents
flipping the flipping the buttons
differently and actually saying like
[ __ ] you
but they know we blur that out on on tv
all the time yeah
yeah they didn't really mention that in
this article but so i'm not sure
but i did notice that other people were
saying like
that's how professional she is like she
had to
actually interpret the entire discussion
of that
situation of like that event that she's
at and so
i don't think she got any like i
wouldn't raise i wouldn't give her any
[ __ ] yeah
she's on it exactly and then uh did you
guys hear what the mayor
responded like what he actually said it
was i understand how upset people are
and i understand
that from where they stand they see it
as being unfair but we're trying to be
as fair as possible in terms of our
public health
and safety that's a very professional
and thank you very much cut up yours
[ __ ] buddy [ __ ] you mother
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you want to see some sign language
come sign language this
dick [ __ ] sound like that song sound
like uh with the governor cuomo
oh for sure exactly except he'd be on
camera though new yorkers
okay it's his own brother
you should call mom mom you never talk
too long
are we are we doing this i mean this
isn't the worst thing
he's like yeah this tissue is bigger
than your dick what are you guys talking
about right now
he's like you all forgot their cameras
your house this is real
i sent some hurt yeah i've always wanted
to learn
sign language same yeah i feel like it's
so useful i feel like i knew the
alphabet in third grade and i
lost it all yeah i don't remember it
very much
you still remember something the ones
that still look like the letters
they're gonna throw ganks at yourself
[Music]
like m n i think um wait isn't it m n
you're probably right um i don't
remember one of those
my brother actually learned sign
language because um he was
he he was just really interested in all
that and he learned it and he ended up
getting a girlfriend out of it and he
was like this [ __ ] came in handy
nice oh that's cool as in she
no she was also into into like learning
learning sign language no she wasn't
deaf
yeah yeah i've heard i've heard people
argue that like oh instead of like some
a lot of the foreign languages that we
teach at school like oh signing should
be like more of a standard just things
that like to teach other people because
it's probably more useful than like some
of the other foreign languages and stuff
and is it international like it's an
international sign language right
it's american sign language no it's
american sign language i think asl
what really the other languages have
different i think is it um i think
the most commonly used one is asl so
you're okay yeah pretty safe
but yeah i think it's specifically
american signing
okay okay gotcha but it's still like i
feel like
i mean it's like it's like learning
english you know and being able to speak
it in most
parts that's true yeah i remember being
in middle school
and um me and my best friend were like
you know what we should study sign
language because
when we're in class we could talk to
each other without needing to pass notes
wow wouldn't it take longer to like get
your message and also it's like
you're gonna be like i hope the teacher
doesn't see me
you really think that's how people sign
that's what she was just doing dude
she's [ __ ] doing opera
because she's in a press conference oh
well i know i don't know
it wasn't they're not that gigantic
she's doing some people in the backpack
how do you whisper sign language well i
know the reason why we got this idea
is because there was a group of kids
that were deaf that were signing all the
time and i'm like
that's [ __ ] tight like they could
just be in class or um
it wasn't in class because they had
different classes but we would see each
other in the quad and they'd be like
talking to each other from like across
the quad or whatever and i'm like that's
[ __ ] tight
like that's just like a whole nother
like
it opens a whole nother possibility
especially when you're in school
and you're a talk talker very talkative
person with your best friend
i'm like dude this is before like text
messages and stuff or like
cell phones this is middle school i mean
yeah this is like 2002
do you think that as scientific
advancements happen with like
deafness and all this stuff so there's
cochlear implants and all this kind of
[ __ ] now
like sign language will be like not even
something that's used i think i think it
probably still will be just because it's
like not everyone will have access to
those things
like it'll be a while before that's like
widely available to everyone on like a
really basic level and stuff like polio
yeah
got it thank you so much ryan but i
think
people don't they sign for other reasons
as well like when they
they have trouble like mute or i don't
know the proper term but like they don't
actually speak
just science needs to fix all that all
of it that's what i'm hoping for in the
next couple decades for sure
true because even blindness some of it
has been
my big thing i'm waiting for is for them
to fix tinnitus
you have that what's tinnitus what is
that it's like you have a constant
ringing in your ears so when it's extra
quiet it's like extra loud
that you hear so like my right ear is
worse than my left so when i go to bed
if i'm paying attention to it at the
time and laying on my right ear it's
super loud if i turn and lay in my right
ear
my uncle has a super bad because he used
to fix radar dishes on
aircraft carriers and so they're
constantly landing planes yeah and she's
just loud
he didn't wear like muffs and all that
he did but it's still so [ __ ] hot
because it's only minus what 20
something db oh i don't know i feel
they're they're hundreds they're huge
though and i figure like they would have
like other plugs and
i don't know although i feel like
sometimes the vibrations can still go
through your body
let alone the earmuffs right like when
i'm at a concert sometimes i'm like i
i feel like even if i have earplugs in
it's going through
my like organs at the moment i'm pretty
sure it'll make it in there or dude my
body has a 50 cal so when he fires that
thing you feel it go through your entire
body like the shocking
concussive blast of you that you feel it
in your chest you're like oh
yeah that's true that does happen that's
crazy
how about you do you feel like do you
have a 50 count
do you fire your fifty calories do you
relate to the feeling of the sound like
moving through your entire body because
like at a concert and stuff yeah
yeah all the time like especially like
if i'm near the front like i always
regret not bringing like ear plugs but
that's a lot at the same time she was
hard at concerts too at the same time i
was like but this is how you enjoy it
[ __ ] it he's not deaf now yeah it's how
you enjoy
what yeah that's what happened to them
she's like huh yeah
do you know where you got your tonight
is from i've always had it a little bit
as a kid like
just a little bit and then it definitely
got worse from going to like music shows
and stuff
yeah i didn't start wearing like
earplugs until probably
just a few years ago after it already
started getting bad but now i always
have earplugs that shows i can't i can't
go like a responsible person as someone
who is already
[ __ ] yeah responsibility
i always forget every time
you